If a cancer is triggered by a virus, isn't the virus still possibly probably active?
If the keyword is if.
So not all cancers are triggered by a virus even though some people write that in books and blogs and stuff.
So remember that.
But if it is triggered by a virus, doesn't mean the virus is still active.
No, it doesn't.
So if a cancer was initially triggered by a bio toxin of any kind, whether.
So remember anything that gets inside of a cell, whether it's a chemical toxicity, whether it's a bio toxin like.
If you need to call or I or back, you know, some other bacteria or virus.
If it damages the nucleus in the cell, that cell.
That nucleus is damaged and it re goes into rapid replication.
It's rapidly replicating another damaged cell that's rapidly replicating.
So it's not the virus is necessarily even even in the body anymore.
So it can be person can still have.
Let's say a person a stomach cancer and they have H by Laura has the cause, which is the number one causes stomach cancer worldwide.
They still have H by Laura most likely because.
How H by Laura is you know, it's most likely that they still have the active H by Laura.
And it's ironic that 90% of people with stomach cancer, the doctor, the oncologist never treats the eggs by Laura.
However, it doesn't always mean with other cancers that may have started from a bio toxin doesn't always mean the bio toxin is present.
That's what's called an active antigen.
So if the if the person has still has an active virus or active bio toxins called an active antigen.
So how you measure that is is partly through a CVC, a complete blood count, which is if you have so remember, like this question back we had back here person has white blood cell cult total leukocytes are total white blood cell cult.
The normal is for to 10 really should be about this should be about five to eight.
Different labs give different normal ranges.
But if you have a total white blood cell count over eight.
You really do have some sort of active infection might be a low grade infection.
But you have some active infection, then you look at the slit of those white blood cells.
These are laser fills, modest sites, lymphocytes and neutrophils.
If the person has elevated lymphocytes, then most likely they have a viral infection.
If they have elevated neutrophils, then most likely they have a bacterial infection.
So that's how you look at a CDC.
But it's a.
If the person like this person, this one, they don't have elevated white blood cells, they have suppressed white blood cells.
Now that can be from a product like parasitic infection or folial infection, not really viral or bacterial.
So you can't do a CD8 CD4 ratio to that's a different little deeper test for that.
And you can see if the person has an active infection with that too.